BRING ME THIS.
THEY BRING ME THIS.
>> JOINING ME NOW IS FORMER
DEFENSE SECRETARY AND CIA
DIRECTOR UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA
LEON PANETTA.
THE WILL OF THE UKRAINIAN PEOPLE
HAS BEEN NOTHING SHORT OF
REMARKABLE, WE SAW THE VIDEO
WHERE THE GENTLEMAN WAS TELLING
ONE OF OUR REPORTERS THAT THE
MOLOTOV COCKTAILS CAME FROM THE
APARTMENT BUILDING ACROSS THE
STREET.
SO THE UKRAINIAN CITIZENS ARE
CERTAINLY PITCHING IN.
BUT WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO
THIS NEWS ABOUT THE TOWN IN
SOUTHERN UKRAINE THAT WAS TAKEN
BY THE RUSSIANS ABOUT 100,000
PEOPLE IN THAT TOWN, AND A SMALL
NAVAL BASE.
IT DOES SHOW THAT THE RUSSIANS
ARE ADVANCING.
>> WELL, LOOK, THERE IS NO
QUESTION WE UNDERSTOOD FROM THE
BEGINNING THE OVERWHELMING FORCE
THAT THE RUSSIANS WERE USING AS
THEY INVADED THE UKRAINE.
BUT THE ENCOURAGING THING IS
THAT THE UKRAINIANS ARE PUTTING
UP A HELL OF A FIGHT.
AND, YOU KNOW, WE'VE ALWAYS
KNOWN THAT FIGHTERS WHO ARE
DEDICATED TO THEIR CAUSE
SOMETIMES ARE MUCH BETTER
FIGHTERS THAN THOSE WHO ARE
INVADING LIKE THE RUSSIANS.
I THINK THAT EVEN THOUGH YOU ARE
GOING TO SEE SOME TOWNS FALL,
WHAT I'M IMPRESSED BY IS THAT
THE UKRAINIANS CONTINUE TO STALL
THE RUSSIAN ADVANCE.
AND I THINK THAT THAT IS AN
IMPORTANT MESSAGE THAT THEY NEED
TO CONTINUE TO WORK AT.
>> YEAH, I WAS JUST SPEAKING
WITH A WESTERN DIPLOMATIC
OFFICIAL HERE IN WASHINGTON WHO
WAS SAYING THAT THERE IS NO
QUESTION RESISTANCE HAS BEEN
STRONGER THAN ANTICIPATED.
AND UKRAINIAN GENERAL SAYS THAT
THEY HAVE CAPTURED ABOUT 200
RUSSIAN SOLDIERS, THAT SOME WERE
19 YEARS OLD, NOT TRAINED AT
ALL.
REPORTS OF RUSSIAN SOLDIERS
BECOMING DISORIENTED SAYING WE
DON'T KNOW WHO TO SHOOT.
THEY ALL LOOK LIKE US.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU?
>> LOOK, I THINK THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING FOR THE UNITED
STATES AND OUR NATO ALLIES IS TO
CONTINUE TO TRY TO ISOLATE
PUTIN.
AND WE'RE DOING THAT WITH
SANCTIONS, BUT WE'RE ALSO SEEING
THAT PUTIN HIMSELF IN MANY WAYS
IS ISOLATED FROM THE RUSSIAN
PEOPLE IN TERMS OF THEIR
CONCERNS ABOUT GOING TO WAR.
IN ADDITION TO THAT, I THINK
THAT IT IS REALLY IMPORTANT
RIGHT NOW THAT WE CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE MILITARY AID TO THE
UKRAINIANS SO THAT THEY CAN
CONTINUE THIS FIGHT.
THEY NEED AMMO, THEY NEED FUEL,
THEY OBVIOUSLY NEED FOOD.
WE NEED TO HELP SUPPLY THEM WITH
WHAT THEY NEED IN ORDER TO CARRY
ON THIS FIGHT.
THE LONGER THAT FIGHT GOES ON,
THE MORE ISOLATED PUTIN WILL BE
AND THE MORE VULNERABLE PUTIN
WILL BE.
>> THEY CERTAINLY NEED MORE THAN
MOLOTOV COCKTAILS.
THAT IS FOR SURE.
AND THE RUSSIANS ARE SUPPOSED TO
TO MEET WITH THE UKRAINIAN
DELEGATION AT THE BELARUS BORDER
TOMORROW.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, I NEED TO
GET YOUR REACTION ON THIS, MR.
SECRETARY, PUTIN PUTTING HIS
DETERRENCE FORCES AS THEY CALL
THEM, HIS NUCLEAR ARSENAL ON
HIGH ALERT.
I MEAN, UKRAINE DOESN'T HAVE A
NUCLEAR FORCE.
THIS IS JUST SABER RATTLING.
WHAT IS GOING ON?
>> I VIEW WHAT PUTIN SAID HERE
AS A SIGN OF WEAKNESS, NOT A
SIGN OF STRENGTH.
IF THINGS WERE GOING WELL, THERE
WOULD BE NO NEED FOR HIM TO EVEN
RAISE THAT KIND OF THREAT TO THE
WORLD AND TO THE UKRAINE.
HE IS OBVIOUSLY TRYING TO SEND A
SIGNAL TO THE UNITED STATES AND
TO OUR NATO ALLIES.
BUT I THINK THAT IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT THAT PUTIN SHOULD
UNDERSTAND HOW STRONG WE ARE
WHEN IT COMES TO NUCLEAR
DETERRENCE.
WE'VE GOT A THREE PRONGED
NUCLEAR DETERRENT THAT CAN
RESPOND TO ANY THREAT.
AND I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
HE UNDERSTANDS THAT IF HE TRIES
TO DO ANYTHING THAT MIGHT
INVOLVE NUCLEAR WEAPONS, THAT HE
IS ENDING NOT ONLY THE PUTIN
REIGN BUT HIS REGIME AS WELL.
>> AND THE UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY SAYS WHAT RUSSIA IS
DOING SHOWS SIGNS OF GENOCIDE
AND THAT THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT
UKRAINE, IT IS ABOUT THE
BEGINNING OF A WIDER WAR AGAINST
EUROPE, HE IS CALLING ON
CITIZENS ALL OVER THE WORLD TO
TAKE UP ARMS AND FIGHT WITH THE
UKRAINIANS.
I MEAN, SOME OF THAT OBVIOUSLY
IS NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
BUT THIS -- I MEAN, THIS
LEADERSHIP THAT ZELENSKYY HAS
SHOWN IN ALL THIS, THIS COURAGE,
THIS PASSION THAT HE HAS SHOWN,
HAS IT TAKEN YOU BY SURPRISE?
>> WELL, I CERTAINLY GIVE HIM
TREMENDOUS CREDIT FOR THE
LEADERSHIP HE IS SHOWING.
I THINK WE'VE ALWAYS KNOWN THAT
LEADERSHIP IS TESTED IN CRISIS.
AND HE HAS REALLY RESPONDED TO
THIS CRISIS AS THE LEADER OF A
COUNTRY THAT OBVIOUSLY IS BEING
INVADED BY A MUCH STRONGER
COUNTRY IN RUSSIA.
BUT I THINK HIS LEADERSHIP IS
VERY IMPORTANT, TRYING TO
INSPIRE UKRAINIANS TO GET OUT
THERE AND RESIST.
I THINK ULTIMATELY THE ABILITY
TO DEVELOP A RESISTANCE MOVEMENT
WITHIN UKRAINE, AND LET'S FACE
IT, THAT IS WHAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN EVEN IF THE RUSSIANS TAKE
OVER MORE TOWNS, WHAT IS GOING
TO HAPPEN IS THAT UKRAINIANS ARE
NOT GOING TO ACCEPT RUSSIAN
RULE.
AND I DON'T SEE -- I DON'T SEE
THE RUSSIANS' END GAME HERE.
I THINK IT IS ONLY TROUBLE FOR
THE RUSSIANS, FOR THEM TO THINK
THAT SOMEHOW THEY ARE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO BRING UKRAINE UNDER
THEIR THUMB.
IT ISN'T GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> AND THE EUROPEAN UNION
APPARENTLY IS MOVING FORWARD
WITH AUTHORIZING THE PURCHASE --
THE FUNDING OF PURCHASING OF
WEAPONS FOR THE FIRST TIME TO
HELP UKRAINE.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT.
THAT IS A BIG STEP.
>> I THINK THAT IS A VERY
IMPORTANT STEP.
I THINK THAT IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT NOW FOR THE UNITED
STATES, FOR OUR EUROPEAN ALLIES,
TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE STRONG
MILITARY AID TO THE UKRAINIANS
AND GETTING THEM TO THEM ANYWAY
WE CAN.
THEY NEED HELP TO BE ABLE TO
RESIST WHAT IS CLEARLY
OVERWHELMING, YOU KNOW, MILITARY
FORCE.
BUT THESE ARE FIGHTERS.
THEY ARE TOUGH FIGHTERS.
AND THEY ARE FIGHTING FOR A
CAUSE THEY BELIEVE IN.
AND I THINK IF THEY CAN CONTINUE
TO PUT UP A STRONG RESISTANCE,
AND STALL THE RUSSIAN AGGRESSION
IN THE UKRAINE, THAT WHAT THAT
MEANS IS THAT IT WILL FURTHER
ISOLATE PUTIN IN TER